well an incredible debate yeah good okay
taking place literally as we speak and
it looks like Bernie and Warren may have
sort of sorted out the issue that they
were having Wow Wow I mean just
everything about this debate very very
interesting I've also I've been sent a
very bizarre picture of the president
also which at some point I want to look
at Elizabeth Warren clearly has a plane
to catch she's heading right out we see
mayor Pete and I think that's chased in
which I truly find to be one of the
strangest names I've ever heard and it
seems religious right is that is that
something about the name chase that
seems to me more religious than I'm
comfortable with I must say but what a
night what a night I I think Andrew yang
had a bad night I think Tom Styer had a
disproportionally good night relative to
his amount of support and I am welcoming
back folks on YouTube I believe that we
are back I need to figure out exactly
how to get things going again on YouTube
I hope people watched the debate and are
aware of everything that went down let
me see here if I can get us going yeah
okay so let's see YouTube I think let me
take a look here I just want to make
sure everything is everything's working
correctly as we go back on YouTube whoa
that was weird that was very very odd
there all right let's see so I think
that we need let's take some things off
the screen if we can this one and this
one
okay very good and then I think that
we're gonna be able to sort of get back
to like our normal streaming setup and
then we'll talk about maybe taking phone
calls and and all of that stuff let's
see here
we'll get our super chats back on the
screen and then I think we're gonna be
in pretty good shape guys I have a
strong feeling that we're going to be
momentarily here we've got that and then
this okay we've got super chats back on
the screen although there aren't
actually any right now okay very good we
are back ladies and gentlemen I hope you
watch the entire debate I am curious to
hear from people what they thought I
also have just been sent something I I
don't know if this is real I genuinely
have no clue whether what I'm about to
show you is real but I'm told that this
is an undoctored picture of Donald Trump
today it's good somebody tell me whether
this could conceivably be real or
whether this is not real
Trump returns to White House photos is
this like a parody account for copyright
William moon this seems to be a real a
real picture and I've never seen
anything like this
I Wow it's just bizarre this has to be
fake right does anybody know
I mean it's genius the comments don't
seem to be referring to this being fake
oh my goodness that that is just
absolutely bizarre folks it is
absolutely bizarre all right so the
debate is over again I I do believe that
Tom Steyer had an okay night yeah at one
point seemed to glitch where he said
American president and he was like sorry
no of course I mean America and then
they just kind of like stopped short
which was weird at one point they cut to
him and he appeared to be eating which
someone else tells me he was just right
in the middle of a sip of water I don't
think it was great I think you know Amy
Klobuchar did okay I don't think there's
gonna be any change I think Joe Biden
did okay he tried to bring a little more
energy I don't expect any big changes
and I think Bernie was consistent and he
answered the questions correctly there
was a big pile on as far as Bernie goes
mayor Pete got a lot of time a lot of
platitudes and not you know as much
substance as maybe some of us might want
I don't know that this moves the needle
very much I think what moves the needle
is the publicity around mayor Pete quote
winning in Iowa the subsequent media
coverage of that remember mayor Pete
claimed victory when no votes had been
counted he just said we were going into
New Hampshire victorious and that has
led to a rise in mayor Pete's New
Hampshire polling I think that more than
anything else is is really the biggest
factor here let's see Super chats that
are coming in we are still looking for
50 new members today we're only at 15
which is it's a kind of a bummer we do
have a coupon code 36 today you save 60%
I talked about how great of a person you
are and the blue bar fills in when
people sign up with join pakman.com
coupon code 36 today let's take a look
here at the super chats that are coming
in benjamin Ezell says thank you so much
for your content love the show thank you
appreciate that
Andrew Dwyer says I feel like Bernie was
too soft on Pete and Joe what do you
think I hope you disagree
I don't think Bern listen Bernie is not
uber confrontational but every time
Bernie was talking about I'm not you
know letting suck-up billionaires
whatever run my campaign stuff he's
talking about mayor Pete right that's
who we that's who the billionaires are
giving a bunch of money to Pete and
that's exactly who Bernie is talking
about I just think it's unrealistic to
expect him to be more confrontational
than he you know that his personality
would dictate Jack Dixon says can you
explain your studio setup no not right
now
I don't know what I mean it's just it's
a you know it's it's a studio we've got
all sorts of equipment but I think we've
got email me if you have a specific
question newah matt says Donald Trump is
Harvey two-face
Justin girly who is a regular and I
really appreciate his support says open
the phone lines please I know whenever
you do open you get so much more support
we all have a lot to say about the night
by the way tom was lit with Bernie on
topic
well I'd consider opening the phone
lines but we've got to get a little
closer to our membership goal it's just
it's a little bit if you know if I say
we need 50 and then I just open them at
15 I am no longer credible it's like
with Trump where if you sign a deal with
the US
and then Trump's like I don't like the
deal I'm cancelling it even though Iran
didn't do anything wrong
then people take advantage of Donald
Trump and the u.s. let's see here
assassin Kane says for me Bernie up Pete
down Amy down
Biden down steyr up Warren down yang out
Bernie winning I also think that the end
could be near for Andrew Yang and I
guess it was just bad timing
when he looked like he was eating when
the camera cut to him and I guess he was
just drinking water and it was just
awkward but I think that time is short
for Andrew Yang's campaign Ricky
Williams says Bernie should add to his
argument that we subsidize the lower
cost for other countries they negotiate
lower for their citizens and drug
companies know they can charge whatever
here to recoup profits I would like to
see more focus on that in general nerd
pants has subscribed at the soy boy
level on YouTube dan alfe's has
subscribed at the soy boy level on
YouTube as well I also want to thank
overrun twitch new midian Nomad for the
twitch Prime subscription five months in
a row I want to say thanks to wheel PO
II for the subscription Jimmy big nuts
has subscribed psycho coaster also a
twitch prime subscriber thank you very
much I I do appreciate that
I believe let's take a look real quick
again at the New Hampshire polling we
were this is California looking at the
New Hampshire polling of course the
purple line over here is Pete Budaj edge
Bernie Sanders also continuing to climb
but Pete Budaj edge closing the gap to
some degree Joe Biden falling in New
Hampshire Elizabeth Warren falling in
New Hampshire and Michael Bloomberg
nowhere remember Michael Bloomberg may
indeed end up in upcoming debates
including the next one but not in this
one and essentially ignoring New
Hampshire completely dead bare our own a
home on Justin Gurley says lol come on
man 15 is great but you ignore the prime
users that hit the goal of a thousand
at the end of the debate that deserves
an open phone line oh boy people are
really getting on me here dead bear says
this is a little off-topic but will you
be doing a segment about joe walsh
dropping out of the race and telling
republicans to vote Democrat probably on
Monday yeah
probably on Monday Benjamin Ezell says I
actually love that Bloomberg is polling
well because it splits the establishment
vote they don't know who to rally around
and that's great for Bernie there's
another approach the other the other
interpretation is what it does is help
to deny Bernie the nomination in other
words it's an asymmetrical situation if
a bunch of people can pick up enough
delegates in total even if Bernie has a
plurality if they can deny him the
number he needs to secure the nomination
they win by forcing a second ballot vote
with super-delegates so there's two
interpretations of that you got to be
careful with that let's see who else
we've got William Gilbert subscribing at
the beta level Richard K please cover
more of the State of the Union on the
show what did you think of the phony
scholarship USA TODAY's has funded
directly by Nancy DeVos I think it's
Betsy DeVos and DeVos has spelled a
little bit differently but I didn't hear
that
we're probably done with so do coverage
for now heads ur head says seemed like
they refused to declare a winner in Iowa
yes
idiot box Bernie's promised the bust of
big corporations has abc's owners and
Disney out to get him that may be a
factor Justin Gurley sends a super
chattin you a mat that says thoughts on
Biden standing ovations for VIN Minh I
thought it was weird
I thought it was quite frankly very very
weird let me say thank you to rob and ad
Tomlinson now I wonder if that's my
friend's parents interesting Ian's
Durocher has subscribed at join
pakman.com and Adam Chambers has
subscribed getting us new members number
16 17 and 18 I also want to say thanks
to pink and blonde for subscribing for
five months with twitch Prime
a CEO five-10 asks whatever happened to
Tulsi aha she failed basically she is
she is out I mean I think she's still
running doesn't his tools he's still
running for president honestly I'm
honestly asking that I guess she must be
right because she was in the list of
people in the Iowa results but she got
zero I think people don't know Tulsi was
in the audience so I didn't know that
that's interesting
she's still running but should drop out
hmm yeah again we were taking a look at
this picture only her which was sent to
me is this real is this a real picture
in fact I think I'm gonna tweet about it
real quick with a comment is this a
photoshopped picture is this real it is
shocking what a bizarre picture I have
never never ever ever seen anything like
that John McClane says when Biden's side
hug Bernie and people defended him it
confirmed
everyone thinks Hillary Clinton is
unbearable he came off as a total phony
a lot of people in my chat feeling that
way Benjamin Iselle has subscribed at
the beta level Toby bonnets says let's
tax on healthy consumables and subsidize
healthy ones to fund healthcare as a
compromise with conservatives Dems will
Stonewall single-payer Justin girly says
it's hard to gift for members for your
show it's very easy to get members on
twitch is shown but super chats make
Bank lol I get it alright listen you
know what Justin girly you're driving me
up a wall my friend I'm gonna just take
a few phone calls merely to reduce the
attack the the brutal attacks from
Justin girly so people have Justin girly
to thank for open let's open the phone
lines a little bit and I'm gonna take it
on faith that people are gonna going to
keep signing up or something all right
let me get connected the number is 6 1 7
8 3 0 47 50 you have Justin girly to
thank for the phone calls I am gonna get
myself connected and I do want to hear
from a few people
we'll see what people thought about the
debate so once again the number is six
one seven eight three zero
4750 let's get connected here thank you
for calling in to the David Pakman show
please do not use speakerphone have your
question ready and listen for David to
call out your area code okay and let's
see I am on all right let's go directly
to Kowalski who is I guess known on the
majority report Kowalski Nebraska
Republican what's up oh it's me
yes it is oh my bad oh I just wanted to
call in and say I think Bloomberg in the
next debate is actually a really good
idea because they need to call him out
on the stage to support whoever the
nominee is going to be they need it on
the record clear as day I thought I
thought Bloomberg recently said he would
not only support the eventual nominee
but pour money in for them I would be
just needs to be on the debate like that
needs to keep getting home din that he's
buying his way in I actually think I'm
being on the debate stage is going to
hurt him which will be a great thing
interesting interesting yeah no I don't
know I really hope all in with and see
if you also maybe wanted some more corn
subsidized money so sorry what was that
Kowalski I missed that oh I'm sorry I
live in rural America so you know our
reception is terrible I was there as if
you enjoyed the subsidized corn money of
course all super chats are much
appreciated and it are you the Kowalski
that calls into Sam's show is that
accurate all the time got it all right
very good
anything agenda today okay I'm sorry
we're talking over each other there must
be that phone lines yes it is all right
Kowalski thank you for the call I look
forward to hearing from you again
I will harass you in the future do you
have a good evening all right you too
our Nebraska Republican corn funded
Kowalski
let's go next to our caller from the 401
to area code potentially calling in from
the Pittsburgh area for one to Iran
oh the Bing yes it is uh so I think what
I got out of a time I know earlier you
were saying through like the general
audience that Pete had a good showing I
kind of disagree and the reason why I
think that is I think that race question
that that the moderator kept she didn't
just let Pete give his platitudinous
like you know yes he called him off hit
him again
yeah she hit him twice I think I think
that will have a bigger impact and some
people are saying like I saw a tweet
earlier today that Joe Biden has what
like fifty seven percent of black
support I think Bernie is 25 and Pete
still pulling at zero and I think I do
can we tweeted that peach support with
blacks just dropped a minus five percent
I just think that hit harder than a lot
of people think we'll see I'm serious I
mean I don't know if it did because
there's a lot of numbers involved and
Pete had a good mr. so the question was
that in Pete's in South Bend there is an
even greater racial inequality in
arrests for drug stuff of non-white
people and Pete came back and said the
total number of arrests went down when I
became mayor which is of course not the
topic at hand I I don't want to say
people are stupid but I just mean people
often are paying attention casually to
these things and it may not have been
super obvious that he wasn't answering I
don't know yeah I would think so I mean
obviously Pete's one of the best on the
debate stage of just giving a word salad
out of you know saying a lot of things
about any substance but officer yeah I I
just feel like on that one that really
for me it was like I was like oh crap
they just got him good on that one I
don't know if that I mean obviously I'm
a Bernie supporter I'd not obviously my
view on this one's a little biased right
but uh yeah I just I feel like that one
really got him alright well we'll see
you up what happens in the polling I'm
curious myself all right thank you Dave
okay thank you great to great to hear
from you let me say a quick thank you to
rob Tomlinson as well as josé de hey
soos who are new
number 19 and 20 at join pakman.com Ryan
F says via super chat DNC caught in
sabotage again Pete still gets a bump we
will see we will see let me go next to
the four four three area code whose
calling today from four four three hi
David this is Trey originally from
Eastern Shore of Maryland a more rural
area of Maryland now I was know as a
Pittsburgh love it what's going on yeah
so I was watching the debate stream on
Twitch and you know this is my first
election but I'm going to be able to
participate in and the first candidate
has got my attention and sort of got a
paying attention to the process was
Andrew yang Oh caliber you know I've
definitely come around to really being
ready for him to get out of the race and
and it looks like this debate
performance was a you know evidence that
it's high time for that he seemed
confused it wasn't clear if he couldn't
hear the questions maybe he was getting
tired because he was not they weren't
going to him very frequently I would
like what do you even think happened
honestly it's hard to tell I don't know
if maybe he and his campaign can see the
writing on the wall and from where he's
not a practiced politician maybe he's
not as good at feigning the strength of
his campaign or maybe he was just having
an off night for some random personal
reason I'm unsure but right yeah
something definitely seems off compared
to a you know relatively strong
performances in a couple previous
debates yeah absolutely I don't know
what else to make of it either yet but
anywho I'm glad that he brought you know
some interesting topics to the you know
general and political awareness such as
you know I had never really been
thinking of automation and you know it's
really so jury out regarding whether you
know automation is actually the key
reason why a lot of jobs are being lost
air
it's just a player but you know how
people are talking about UVI which could
be a valuable part of a progressive
platform but not really in the way that
he was trying to introduce it so now I'm
pretty much with Bernie Wow all right
very good well I appreciate you letting
me know your point of view there prime
you have a great day all right thank you
so much
via super chat Rory drew says David I've
been watching your interview with Jesse
Lee Peterson from a couple years back
you deserve a knighthood I applaud your
composure I'm gonna be back in LA soon I
was thinking of reaching out about doing
another one Sheehan says Yang needed
some of trumps sudafed uppers yeah yang
was like low-energy today very very
low-energy let's go next to we've got a
lot of people holding just so people
know there's 25 people holding right now
just so you get a sense of how
jam-packed things are let's go to the
seven five four area code who's calling
from 754 David yes well yes David yeah
oh wow actually sorry I was I'm speaker
am i off speaker now you tell me my
friend okay I'm off speaker I'm just
wondering if you can hear me oh well you
know all of a sudden I can hear you much
better okay great so my name is David -
I love your show thank you really really
love your show
and I'm actually not from I guess 9 1 7
is Florida but I've got a family planned
with my sister I'm actually at New Haven
Connecticut and I don't even know what 9
9 1 7 is because you're you're coming in
at 75 for area code my friend so I mean
seven five four nine one seven two New
York all right there's no bosses okay so
anyways your phone number which is a
good start I'm psyched and I hope you're
not mad because I've been wanting to get
in touch with you and ask you this
question but it's not really about the
debate tonight but I really want to ask
this question well I hope destiny just
raided my stream with almost 5,000
viewers so if you ask a question that is
embarrassing to my broadcast there are
5,000 new people that are going to be
absolutely furious with you well I
it's not embarrassing to your broadcast
if it's embarrassing it's just gonna be
embarrassing to me but this is what I
wonder because we know I mean I feel
Republicans play extremely dirty when it
comes to you know voter suppression and
I think it's pathetic the voter turnout
that we have even you know here
regardless of the so I'm wondering
regards on there's a lot of religious
I'm sure I said here regardless two
words mean the same thing I actually
interviewed someone from a dictionary
it's the boat the words mean the same
thing isn't that crazy
okay how about irregardless irregardless
I like it it's things are getting even
crazier
I believe that Tom Stiers twitch account
is now hosting us and I actually think
that my sarcastic positive comment about
him on Twitter I think they're taking it
seriously oh wow performance alright
let's let's hear your question I
apologize okay
alright I have to go back actually go
back and catch the first half of the
debate because I wasn't around but so I
always wonder why I mean we have a lot
of good very rich people you know who in
billionaires even yes it why don't they
put together it like pool their money
and start this is for the election like
lotos or contests private contests where
if you go and vote that that's your
entry to the lottery you know what I
mean no motivated you to go out you they
vote and then you're entered in a
lottery like like a state-run lottery I
mean it's a contest and the person who
wins gets like a million dollars and and
they could you know one got Mark Cuban
could do Texas or whatever you know
anything and then people would go out
and you so let me see I just want to
really make sure I'm understanding what
you're I'm almost positive what you're
suggesting is illegal but let's imagine
it's not you're saying that's what I
want to ask you when you go and vote if
it's illegal and why and by voting you
are entered into a lottery in which you
can win a million dollars
exactly and we're despite I mean just
proving that you vote for private
billionaires and millionaires and people
who want to get demmick
vote out I know people who are
disenfranchised or whatever I think it's
almost certainly illegal I don't - I
said I know that it could be yeah and
but I think it could be done where it's
not illegal like an online conscience I
mean people give away money all the time
and just because it's related to I mean
I I feel that they could get around it
if they wanted you maybe so I don't
think it's a stranger or at least very
particular I don't know that it's
something you could say so let's say
it's not illegal I don't know what you
do with that necessarily about hello huh
okay all right welcome to everybody
joining me from Destiny's stream there's
a super chat from YouTube that's a
message to you guys
numbered says tell the destiny fans in
the chat to vote Bernie also machine XP
one thing we've been talking about is
what happened to Andrew yang tonight
machine XP says huge yang fan but
honestly it feels like he was
overwhelmed with a lack of time to speak
and terrible performance with Iowa boats
also Justin Gurley sends a message just
saying 0.36 0 oh I guess Justin Gurley
may be holding let's see is there a 3 6
0 call holding 3 6 0 is this Justin
Gurley hey how you doing miss Justin hey
Justin you've been busting my choppa all
night well yeah III think that uh you
know the best part of your show viewers
calling it alright well now I want to
talk about it be well oh no your new
preview being all I who gets me to open
the phones and then you we can't hear
you because of your connection how
embarrassing that is embarrassing um all
right you're back on through some
concrete that ok yes hello now he's just
gone altogether so we now we just lost
him completely
can you imagine let's go to valve from
Agawam we haven't heard from valve for a
little bit hey Val what's going on hi
David how are you doing good thing
you thanks for doing the stream again of
course as always it's much appreciated
thank you I kept my Jackie very quiet
during the entire course of the debate
right that's a Jack Russell Chihuahua
crossbreed hybrid as you call it yes
it's a hybrid thank you
but anyway I think Bernie did really
well I would like to see Bernie be
stronger though I know it's not in his
nature and I don't know maybe maybe this
is all part of the grand plan that he
has but I would like to see him defend
himself I've seen him get one too savage
mode quite a bit on some old YouTube
clips yeah that's the but I understand
what you're saying I don't know that so
there were a couple other people be a
super Chad who also said they wanted to
see a much more aggressive Bernie I
think Bernie repeating a few times that
he's not being funded by a bunch of
billionaires I feel like that is Bernie
being aggressive I don't know how much
more aggressive he's gonna get really
true that's true and I think I think him
just stating it matter-of-factly might
even be a better idea actually yeah now
that you mention it I think that
hammering on that is a good idea I don't
know how much if if the problem is if
the if a casual viewer doesn't realize
when Bernie says I don't have all these
dozens of billionaires funding me if you
don't know that that's what Pete has you
might not even understand the attack
that's true no that's a good point and
at this point we really have to start
spelling things out for people I think
you know for people that are just tuning
in that haven't seen other to be
absolutely there are people only now
getting involved now that the Iowa
caucuses have happened but in any case
we we may see a totally different
dynamic by the next debate we might have
yang out and we might have Bloomberg in
and who knows what's happening with
steyr so it could be a very different
feel in the next debate this is true
yeah now quickly on another topic please
are their destiny people listening to
this yes there are because I really
think we need to make at the risk of
sounding like that
person that says they want to go bowling
yeah children of the lie has to happen
yeah I know everybody thinks it's a joke
for people who are coming here from the
destiny Channel Jesse Lee Petersen uses
this phrase to describe leftists
children of the lie so I had the idea
that we should do a single song like I
said we it would be a band under the
name children of the lie we put out one
song I play drums
Steven Destiny's Bunnell ii plays keys
Anthony Destiny's bonel the second now
Anthony Fantana plays bass and Sam cedar
sings and I am serious about it and I
told them all about it and they were all
kind of like yeah sure but then when I
followed up nobody nobody responded and
I can't be the guy who keeps taking it
seriously if they aren't you know Val
because then I lose I become beta and I
feel like you have to remain alpha very
important I need the audience to get
them involved and then we will do it I
think it would be an amazing thing to do
so this is my pitch to seriously make
that happen
yeah oh that was you we just had a [ __ ]
very good that is a pitch yes I would
like that to happen all right Val we
will we will research and try to make it
a reality okay take care baby all right
Val thank you so much great to hear from
you let me thank a couple other people
who signed up at join pakman.com we'll
border is numb remember number 21 and
then Steven Werner is member number 22
and oh that's it okay just those two
people a couple super chats Richard K
says David on the line about Betsy DeVos
area code 4 to 5 I don't know if we're
doing everybody's super chats there
they're actually I don't even have a 4
to 5 up on up right now heads or head
says if I got a super chat my area code
I will do it it's eight one six let me
see if I see an eight one six here okay
I do see eight one six let's try eight
one six eight one six is this heads or
heads yeah this is him
how you doing I actually make good I'm
doing doing well actually actually
music so if you want to get that train
going I will happily produce but I kept
I became a member today after listening
for a long time my mom actually got me
into you with the Petersons interview oh
that's why I like well I'd love to yeah
I would love to see a you know another
sequel to that but I think something
that kind of got a overlooked by like
Bernie as a solid attack an attack a
solid point that he should make yeah is
that he won an overwhelming amount of
non-white voters in Iowa and in fact got
more than double the support that Joe
Biden got what so I thought that that
was a missed opportunity for sure and
also you know you got 43% of the vote of
people under the age of 45 which is just
an enormous amount that I think those
numbers really can kind of translate
into some serious solid you know like
look I have the support I got it in
actual votes that we all along we've
been talking about well it's like slow
people vote and now we have one state we
can look at those results and it seems
like nobody talked about any I mean I
understand not talking about Iowa
because it's such a mess but yeah at
least if you're going to make a case for
why you're the most electable person you
might as well use the numbers that you
have at your disposal
and Bernie did it one though I won Iowa
by six thousand votes or something
ignoring the delegate question and I
thought that was relatively clever right
right
and and kind of what I've been seeing is
that this might be a positive for Bernie
in you know on that positive in the
sense that for everyone who's kind of
been keeping not a close eye on Isis
early on on the race they see the amount
of you know the hiccup that has happened
and you know the cluster that has
happened with Iowa and yeah you know
it's now coming down to a tiny sliver
putting who Pete like everyone's like
who was this it was this and I think
that people are starting to you know
even if it's you know not true there's
true they're trying to see it as as the
Democratic sir again Reagan against
Bernie which whether or not that will
help him to be seen but I wanted to get
your thoughts on on what happens if Pete
wins New Hampshire and Bernie gets
second in terms of the upcoming I mean
if so if Pete wins New Hampshire
I believe the establishment likely
unites behind Pete and that they kind of
a band
Byron and Biden already in the results
is not doing not doing well if Bernie
wins New Hampshire but Pete is second
you maybe still see the same thing and
if Biden is second in New Hampshire or
wins I think the establishment probably
stays behind Biden for you know some
further period of time
sure and and at what point do you think
you know Warren supporters decide well
it there's no path you know viable path
for Warren to get the nomination well I
think half of them already decided that
she's lost about half of her support
right a few months but I think very soon
I mean unless she gets something
happening in the next couple of states
Warren's done right yeah I mean that's I
guess it's just interesting to see what
will happen and and do you think that
anyone will declare a winner before New
Hampshire votes in an Iowa oh yeah I
think we will know who won Iowa before
before New Hampshire votes yes all right
you've gotten a number of questions in
so I'm gonna let you go we typically
limit it to just one Kowalski from
Nebraska says don't tell Sam but here
have some cattle cache thank you Justin
Gurley says thanks for opening the line
sorry about my reception sometimes it
works sometimes it drops it dropped with
my luck but the Magic eight Ball says
try again okay let's see let's go to the
our caller from the four eight zero area
code I believe four eight zero is that
is that the Tucson Arizona area yeah I
David this is a suspense er from hey
how's it going love to son yeah yeah
good place um I'm pretty I'm just
wondering so I was expecting tonight
with the whole debacle and I was at the
ABC hosts would bring that up I'm just
wondering what your take is on why we
didn't see that I think that there was
an agreement not to I think that there I
would be shocked if the DNC didn't
express that they would rather it not be
brought up there was no mention of it
other than Bernie saying he got the most
votes which is accurate so I believe
that it was a joint decision and that
the DNC said listen with things they're
crazy it's not
be good for anybody for it to come up
it's not gonna be productive and we
don't want you bringing it up an ABC
probably agreed gotcha oh yeah that
makes sense I figured maybe like the
questions were pre-written
because otherwise it seems like me would
be something that might be good for
ratings but I could see why they might
want to just avoid it altogether yeah
yeah I think that it was there
the DNC did not want it brought up and
clearly they must have made their point
known got it okay great thanks David all
right very good great to hear from you
Shion says via super chat who's a bigger
threat to Bernie now Pete or Biden well
I think mathematically now it's Pete
Pete is rapidly surging and in early
states may do better than Biden in at
least up until South Carolina but we'll
see let's go to Sam from the - OH -
Sam's calls have been interesting
historically based on the notes I have
in front of me what's going on Sam
hi David can you hear me I can hear you
okay I have a question so Andrew yang
and Clovis are my two favorites for but
Andrew yang said something interesting
city that kept the whole capitalism
versus socialism thing is out it is like
kind of outdated and I have two things
on that one all the countries that
Sanders wants us to be like they are
capitalist yet they have a huge safety
net and a lot of people miss that that
they're still technically capitalist and
we all know that state socialism like
like the Soviet Union collapsed and
China had to become way more capitalist
yeah in the Navion countries northern
Europe those are capitalist countries
you're completely right Sam yeah a lot
and a lot of people like capitalism
versus socialism they're missing the
whole point B I think you can have a
good Society in capitalism or in
socialism because in the United States
the 1950s and 60s we were doing great
and we have an even smaller government
but the difference being the
billionaires of the billionaires in
today's money were had far less than
influence in our government and in fact
we had the Republican President
Eisenhower
talking about the military-industrial
complex complex uh buying our government
and like the corruption we have today is
unheard of and we were capitalist back
then and we had an even smaller
government than now and they have
similar results to what we had back then
in terms of prosperity and whatnot in
Sweden and whatnot so my point is you
can have an equal amount of prosperity
in a ton of different systems so that's
why I think it's out a day
all right Sam very good always eloquent
and always right to the point I
appreciate the phone call the points are
well made Eduardo Castillo or as we
would say in Argentina Castillo says
what do you think of Pete's concept that
you don't bring a knife to a gun fight
until campaign finance reform has been
overhauled the Dems need to fight fire
with fire that seems reasonable money
versus money I've always agreed I mean
it when I report to you Oh Bernie raised
a record 25 million or whatever I don't
like the system but given that it's the
system we have someone on our side needs
to raise money and get in office right I
mean otherwise that nothing it's not
gonna work
let's go to our caller from the 7-3 to
area code who's calling today from seven
three two hi Connor from feeding Hills
Massachusetts go feeding Hills you're
near valve from Agawam yes I am very
cool ah yes and and I do not appreciate
you insulting her Jack gee that was very
discriminatory of you against who
bowels Jack she was it was oh it was
discriminatory against that one dog yes
exactly
got it against whom I'm sorry so I by
Counting because I want to ask you this
question which was during the
impeachment trial yes I had this eye
seeing a few articles go over this that
fundamentalists they're not
fundamentalist I guess a fundamentalist
an originalist interpretation like the
Conservatives obsess over with their
judges yes of the impeachment clauses of
the Constitution would note that it
gives it
notes that the Chief Justice is the
presiding officer and says that and but
it never said the Senate can make rules
that are overriding him
so why didn't what Roberts like with
that logic interfere more in it do you
think you just didn't want to get caught
up with some sort of weird
constitutional crisis type deal oh of
course
justice Chief Justice John Roberts in
his role in the impeachment trial had no
interest in doing anything other than
getting it over with as quickly as
possible he wanted to stay as still as
possible blend into the background and
have people forget that he's there and
there was there was never the chance
that he was actually going to get
involved and his role was merely
procedural and I mean he did he did he
refused to read two of Rand Paul's
questions and other than that I can't
think of anything he actually asserted
yeah and then that and I noticed at the
end of work what did the Republicans do
they gave him like a golden gavel or
something it's like we just witnessed
like bribery it was right at the end
like they have it right in her front
right in front of our faces it was it
was embarrassing him it basically a
participation trophy for sitting there
during the impeachment sham trial it was
it was it was inconceivable that of ten
years ago it would have been
inconceivable that that was going to
happen last week and yet it did and here
we are yeah it makes me think that how
different that would have gone down if
it was a democratic chief justice well
remember the chief justices are not
strictly speaking partisan but of course
Chief Judge Roberts appointed by by a
Republican all right great to hear from
feeding Hills the little brother of
Agawam Massachusetts of course that is
going to do it for me today I appreciate
everybody joining me sorry I wasn't able
to take more phone calls but it's been a
long stream and we will have